over 15 years into its run
ncis has had members of its team
kidnapped
shot stabbed and even blown up by
terrorists
but one of the most shocking deaths came
just two seasons in
here's the real reason sasha alexander
who portrayed kate todd
left ncis after season two we know the
ncis team works long hours to catch the
bad guys but the people who make the
show
are also pulling very long shifts purely
in the name of entertainment
this detail slipped by fans who were so
furious when todd was killed off
that show creator don belisario weighed
in on what happened behind the scenes
he explained that he'd already started
working on the script for the last
episode of the season
when alexander begged him to write her
out of the show in july 2005
a couple of months after todd's dramatic
death aired belisario shed some light on
the situation in a conversation with the
chicago tribune saying
sasha came in two days before i was to
leave and with tears in her eyes she
said
i just can't work this hard the
showrunner admitted that ncis is quote
a hard show to make we work very long
hours he also added that although
alexander was
technically under contract to cbs he
persuaded the network's brass to let her
go
while belisario and alexander knew what
was coming
no one else knew about her departure
fans got wind that
one of the ncis team was going to die in
the season 2 finale but
exactly who it would be was kept so
secret that they reportedly even shot an
alternate ending where todd survived
we're ncis agents mcgee there's a chance
one of us might die
every time we walk through the door
bellisario isn't the only one to ever
lend credence to the idea that working
on ncis could be taxing to the point of
exhaustion for some of his stars
mark harmon who has portrayed special
agent leroy jethro gibbs on the series
for 17
grueling years has spoken in the past
not only about how difficult to gig ncis
can be but about how it used to be even
more so early in the series run
during the series 16th season harmon had
a chat with entertainment tonight in
which he acknowledged that the job isn't
exactly a walk in the park
saying this is hard to do and we miss
that sometimes because this is a happy
group and we all work hard
but this looks so much easier than it is
and that's because you've got such
talented people in so many different
directions here who all get in the same
path of what they're trying to do
in a 2017 interview with the talk harmon
described the early days of the series
in terms that suggest a schedule that
was
nothing short of brutal saying the first
day was
21 hours we've i think maneuvered the
schedule over the years to make
it much more specific and i think we've
gotten better with that
it's interesting to consider that the
character of kate todd might have been a
longer-lived one had producers gone with
their initial choice for the role
in a conversation with cbs news harman
revealed that lauren hawley
who portrayed director jenny shepard on
ncis from seasons three to five
almost landed the part before it was
handed to alexander at the time that
sasha was hired
lauren was in that mix to play that role
and the fact that her name came back up
again for the role jenny shepard did not
surprise me a lot because of what holly
has as an actress
holly must have boundless energy because
when asked why she chose to depart the
series after only three seasons she gave
a much different reason
she wanted to take on different roles
and was unhappy at bellisario's
departure from the show
on her personal website holly wrote i
was saddened that don belisario was
forced out and i missed him
a lot to be honest now that the work bug
had bitten me again
i got bored with my part of the director
then the decision was made to kill me
and
boy did they about five different ways
fortunately it seems that alexander is
more than happy with her decision to
leave
in a 2012 interview with tv guide she
reiterated that she only left because
she personally couldn't handle the long
hours
people don't realize that on a network
show you make 24 episodes a year that's
10 and a half months a year
17 hours a day it's hardcore alexander
wasn't just thinking about the show's
impact on her work
life balance at the time she added i
really firmly believe in my heart that i
would not be where i am today i didn't
want to wake up and be in my 40s and go
oh my gosh but people don't understand
taking the risk and leaving ncis did
seem to pay off personally and
professionally two years after her
dramatic exit alexander married italian
director eduardo ponte
the couple now have two children and she
also gained a famous mother-in-law
none other than iconic actress sophia
loretta career-wise alexander went on to
play half of
crime solving double act rizzoli and
iles for seven seasons
and appeared in the showtime comedy
series shameless todd may have taken one
for the ncis team but alexander is happy
that she's no longer sacrificing her
real life
for the screen check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite actors
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]